BLACKOUTS:
When I visited India when I was 8
years old, I was surprised to see that the power
was shut off for a few hours every single day. At
the time, my main concern was: how do I watch
TV or how do I use the internet when the power
was off. But, looking back, these were the
least of people’s concerns. No power meant
that refrigerators couldn’t be run and that small
businesses and hospitals had to pay for generators
on a daily basis. For many people living there,
this was just a harsh reality of daily life.
Naturally, you would assume that this is only an
issue in developing countries, but one developed
country that’s very much facing this same issue
is none other than Japan. Japan has not only had
to implement electricity saving measures like
turning down the heat and dimming the lights,
but they’ve been experiencing full on blackouts.
The country with internet speeds of 319 terabits
per second and bullet trains capable of reaching
603 km/h is struggling to keep the lights on.
At first glance, you might be driven to think that
this is due to Japan’s economic situation. After
all, it’s no secret that Japan has been facing
an economic crisis for decades. They have a debt
to GDP ratio of 257%, they’re stock market
hasn’t made a new all time high in 33 years,
and the Japanese Yen is at 35 year lows
against the US dollar. All of these would
be great reasons for Japan to cut back on power
consumption and try to save some money. But,
their economic crisis is not the main reason that
they’re also facing an energy crisis. In fact,
Japan would likely be facing an energy crisis even
if they’re economy was booming. The problem would
actually probably be worse because people
would likely consume even more power if the
economy was booming. But then, if the problem
isn’t being able to pay for it, what is? Well,
for Japan, the problem is actually getting
their hands on electricity. For decades,
80 to 90% of Japan’s energy has been imported. For
perspective, only about 7% of America’s energy is
imported. This has become one of Japan’s biggest
bottlenecks and despite their best efforts,
they’ve been unable to escape the shackles of
energy dependence. But, how did such an advanced
and developed country end up in a situation
where they can’t even keep the lights on?
ENERGY DEPENDENCE:
Taking a look back, Japan’s energy crisis wasn’t
something that developed overnight. It’s something
that developed over a century dating back to the
1800s. It all started with a man named Emperor
Meiji who rose to power in 1868. When he took
over, much of Japan was filled with a bunch of
samurais that were constantly in conflict with
each other. There wasn’t much of a society or
an economy, but Emperor Meiji was determined to
change this. He wanted to implement practical
imperial rule and focus on economic growth
and enlightenment. One of the first things
he did was abolish Japanese domains which
were basically the estates of super powerful
landlords within the empire. Instead, he gave
these powerful landlords positions as governors
within the new empire. Emperor Meiji also moved
to eliminate clashes between various armies and
clans. He merged all the armes into one Japanese
military and mandated that all Japanese men must
serve atleast four years in the armed forces. He
figured that fighting side by side would help them
put aside their differences and work together,
and he was right. The entire area became more
united than ever and capitlistic ideologies were
starting to spread. Emperor Meiji even went as far
as establishing a national assembly and allowed
Japanese citizens to vote. Clearly, even though
Meiji was an emperor by name, he wasn’t what you
would normally associate with emperors. He wasn’t
a power hungry man that was only concerned about
increasing his own wealth and well being. No,
he truly wanted to revolutionize Japan and make
the empire a force to be reckoned with. While
Meiji had all of these crazy ambitions, there was
one thing that he was never willing to do which
was give up Japanese independence whether that
be political independence or energy independence.
This didn’t mean that he blocked out the west
altogether though. He was very much willing
to listen to their ideas and take their advice,
but he wanted all growth to originate from Japan
itself. And that’s exactly what happened. As the
textile and railroad industries grew, so did the
coal production industry. During Meiji’s reign,
Japan’s silk exports grew from 646 tons to 9462
tons. But, their coal production grew even more
from 0.66 million tons to 23.5 million tons. By
the time Emperor Meiji died in 1912, the Japanese
empire had become the most developed nation in
east Asia and this kind of got to their head.
They would provoke the United States by bombing
Pearl Harbor and that didn’t really end all
that well for them. By the end of WW2, Japan
was devastated and occupied by Americans, but
while Japan may have been physically destroyed,
their spirit and pride was still very much intact.
They may have lost the conquest war, but they sure
as hell weren’t gonna lose the economic war.
And fortunately for them, the west was very
much on their side. Having capitlistic success
stories in the east with Japan and South Korea
was very much important for the west and their war
against socialist China and the USSR. So, the west
supported Japan all the way and before you knew
it, the country was booming. There was just one
minor issue. Japan’s natural resources couldn’t
keep up with the west supported steroid growth.
If this was during regular times, Japan probably
would’ve considered more sustainable options,
but tensions were high with the Cold War
and Japan had way too much to prove. So,
in 1960, the Japanese government allowed
imported oil to compete with domestic coal
as a prime source of energy. And this marked
the beginning of Japan’s energy dependence.
NUCLEAR:
Throughout the 1960s,
Japan would experience some of most explosive
economic growth numbers ever recorded. Their
energy dependence also skyrocketed from 42%
to over 90%, but very few people saw this as
a problem. Many people actually saw this as an
advantage. You see, Japanese coal production was
extremely expensive relative to the US and
Europe due to poor mining conditions. So,
importing oil from Middle Eastern countries
not only solved Japan’s energy bottleneck,
but it also reduced energy prices substantially.
At first, this seemed like a win-win scenario up
until 1973 when Japan first witnessed the horrors
of energy dependence. This year, OPEC would
introduce an oil embargo against the US and all
of their allies which of course included Japan.
With rising tensions regarding Israel, Japan and
Europe knew that this could be a possibility,
and that’s why they stocked up on oil before the
embargo. But, even with that, oil prices in Japan
grew four to five fold. For perspective, the
gas price run up that we saw earlier this year
was barely a two X from the lows. Fortunately,
this oil embargo only lasted about 5 months,
but Japan was very much scarred for life. And
their tone regarding economic growth flipped on
its head from maximizing growth no matter what to
just achieving moderate sustainable growth. But,
this would turn out to be nearly impossible. The
energy consumption of Japan had become so large
that there was no way for the country to support
themselves based on traditional fuel sources like
oil and coal. So, they had think outside the box
and brainstorm newer methods of energy generation,
and what they landed on was nuclear power. Japan
already had already dabbled with nuclear power
in the past having opened their first plant
in 1966. But, after 1973, expanding nuclear
power generation became their number one priority.
This was by no means a fast process, but Japan was
deteremined. They consistently opened one plant
after another, and within the next 20 years, Japan
was able to grow their nuclear power generation
from 3,000 MW to 43,000 MW. This brought down
their energy dependent from over 90% down to 78%.
There was obviously still a long way to go, and a
full on transition would likely take a century,
but Japan was commited and persistent. For them,
this was no longer a matter of just keeping
energy prices low, it was a matter of maintaining
economic and political autonomy. You know, it’s
never a good thing when a foreign power can pull
the plug on your entire country. But all of this
progress would be stopped dead in its tracks in
2011. This year, Japan would experience the worst
earthquake they ever recorded which caused as
tsunami as well. The nuclear power plants would
automatically shutdown as soon as they detected
the earthquake, but the subsequent tsunami would
flood the Fukushima plant and lead to radioactive
contamination. Over the next few days, 110,000
people would have to be evacuated from nearby
areas and the Fukushima disaster is ranked as
the second worst nuclear disaster in history
only beaten out by Chernobyl. I don’t think
you’d be surprised to hear that public sentiment
strongly turned against nuclear power following
this incident. With all this opposition, Japan had
no choice but to shut down their remaining plants
making them more energy dependent than ever.
A HYDROGEN FUTURE:
With an energy dependence of well over 90%,
it’s not surprising that Japan has to deal with
conserving power and blackouts despite being
a developed country. Japan hasn’t quit trying to
become self sustainable though. They’ve hatched up
a new idea involving hydrogen instead of nuclear
power. It turns out that while Japan doesn’t have
much coal or oil, they have a bunch of hydrogen.
The ocean floors surrounding Japan are filled
with it. This is by no means a new discovery.
The reason that these reserves weren’t already
leveraged was due to technological limitations.
You see, the ocean floors aren’t filled with
hydrogen itself. They’re actually filled with a
sherbert-like substance that’s often referred to
as Fire Ice. To extract this fire ice, you first
have to voyage deep into the ocean where the depth
is over a 1000 meters or nearly 3300 feet. From
there, you have to drill hundreds of meters into
the sea floor to actually extract the fire ice.
It’s not just plug and play from there either.
You then have to extract the methane inside the
fire ice and then convert it to hydrogen. On the
brightside, each cubic meter of methane hydrate
is able to produce 160 cubic meters of methane
gas which can be converted to hydrogen. So, you
definitely get a bunch of bang for your buck,
but that doesn't make it any easier to extract.
The Japanese have been working on a new
drilling method that can transport the fire ice
through underwater pipelines directly to Japan,
but that’s still very much in the beta phases of
development. Figuring all of this out is only half
the battle though. The second half of the battle
is actually getting people to use it. It looks
like they’ve definitely got Japanese companies on
board given that Toyota, Honda, and Nissan are all
working on hydrogen vehicles. But, it’s not clear
if Japanese citizens will actually choose these
offerings over traditional EVs, especially given
that hydrogen vehicles and the hydrogen itself is
rather expensive. Fortunately, Japan isn’t betting
it all on hydrogen. They’re very much working on
bringing back nuclear power. Given that it’s
been over a decade since the Fukushima nuclear
disaster, tensions have significantly cooled
down, and the public has become much more open
to the idea of nuclear power especially when they
see the blackouts first hand. With winter around
the corner in the northern hemisphere, people
are likely going to turn up heaters which will
only worsen the issue. This is why Japan’s
prime minister is pushing to reopen as many
as nine nuclear reactors this winter. But, while
that could help with getting through the winter,
Japan will still very much be in an energy crunch
for the foreseeable future and that’s why Japan is
struggling to keep the lights on. Do you support
nuclear energy? Comment that down below. Also,
drop a like if you hope Japan figures something
out for the sake of their citizens. And of course,
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered.